this is really a problem in Germany
space of about 113 Hector converted in
settlement and traffic area per day that
means that about 50 to 60 Hector are
seared within one day in Germany the
ceiling means that all exchange
processes between the soil Zepeda sphere
and the atmosphere and the Vice VR
interrupted that leads to higher air
temperatures we all know that as urban
heat islands and this is due to the fact
and that we have a ceiling on the top of
the soil and the vegetation cover is
then destroyed and yeah this heat island
is caused of course by various factors
as wind speed or wind direction or the
surface heating but it depends on the
soil and soil properties as well as this
effect of the coverage is very known for
years now but what it's not known is the
impact of the soil and the soil
properties and processes in the soil and
that impact on the local climate this
depends on as a material substrate than
the organic carbon content or the
texture of the soil or even the
anthropogenic land use and we are
analyzing the impact of these factors on
the water availability of course on the
physical soil properties and then the
impact from this physical soil
properties on the exchange processes and
that's a local climate effect we showed
that different water mounts in the soil
and also that means the different soil
properties has an influence on the local
climate we have yes town districts with
higher and ground water table dads and
their the temperature and amplitude was
less high that means that we have a kind
of cooling effect it's a regulation its
climate regulation effect
and then it is transferable to other
towns or metropolitan regions